[Music]
then we'll just get on there working of
us run peel the essent football Pro
Rashad Jennings withstood the 90-degree
heat at the Baywatch movies slow-motion
marathon in LA he judged the race but
over on Dancing with the Stars he's the
one getting critiqued you're pretty much
considered a major front runner for the
finals at this point what are you going
to do from here to make sure that you do
make it in there I keep my head down and
just I'm diving into the dance every
single week I'm buying into everything
that emma my partner is teaching me and
just trying to let my personality show
out on the dance floor so I'm just going
to stick to the work that's it I
actually ran in the slo-mo marathon I
did not win and by the way if you're
sweatin over sexy Rashad we found out he
is single and we're guessing even more
ladies are interested in him with his
newfound dancing fame just focus on
accomplice and everything I want in life
but if somebody got the master key to my
heart I can't stop that but I'm not I'm
not I'm not really looking what kind of
person could get the master key to your
heart I gotta be goofy all right they
got to be intellectually driven they
have to want to leave a legacy in life
they got it they got to be
health-conscious they got to laugh first
easygoing every everyday type of guy and
so she got to be that type of girl